James Corden Neil Patrick Harris
bringing back their singing telegrams
last night on The Late Late Show and it
was magical now I use that word because
that's what Neil is all about did you
know he puts a little magic into
everything at work at play and of course
with his two kids our kids like magic
you have to be careful as a magician to
show kids too much magic because then
that's all they want to see and when
those kids are your own they just like
are constantly asking you to make things
turn into other things or vanish or
appear Neil performed a little sleight
of hand for us making a tissue disappear
really squeeze it can you see that
squeeze squeeze squeeze so it's so small
that advantages he's also pretty good
with a pen writing his second children's
book the magic misfits the second story
that's exciting being a writer
especially for books for people of all
ages our kids Harper and Gideon just are
starting the second grade and they're
just starting to read so we've been
reading these to them and they're very
intrigued and loving the story which is
a big thumbs up and them a little thumbs
up from done they're seven and although
Halloween is just over a month away the
family is getting ready for their annual
photo I already bought Gideon a ninja
outfit he wanted to be a ninja we bought
him a whole ninja outfit and now he
wants to be one of the characters from
halo like dude I bought you a ninja
costume you have you chose Ninja know
it's all halo that's like my house every
single year I you know it's hard to
believe that Dookie Houser premiered 29
years ago this one's crazy that babyface
and I feel so
[Music]
[Applause]